the incredible shonda rhimes created a
cultural phenomenon with bridgerton who
is into bridgerton hi
we love it
and now the kit reports bridgeton is
going bridal fashion experts say brides
are looking for a regency era touch for
their wedding dresses empire waistlines
delicately embroidered flowers and bows
for days bows
and hey if the pearls fit then wear them
honey especially on your wedding day
don't you think i mean maybe drew my
wedding's coming up maybe i'll be in a
girdle
or a corset or a core set yeah i'd love
to see you in a corset or like the wig
that the queen wears i mean you and i
we've gotten to interview people from
bridgerton we've talked about bridgeton
on the news we always do a little
dawning oh well we saw that nod too
well speaking of whimsical weddings our
next story comes from the not that's
right we've got their cover boy for
their summer issue right here and it's
our very own ross matthews
[Applause]
now
this is
obviously ross and that is wellington
ross's fiancee and guess who's actually
here today welly
[Applause]
my well you guys hear me talk about them
all the time there he is
now let me ask you guys a question
because i will say you know
i i'm and i'm by the way i'm the flower
girl at the wedding so she is she is i'm
very i know isn't that exciting i have
my dress upstairs it's so special
but you guys just look like you're
having so much fun in your engagement
like are you guys enjoying it as much as
we feel it and see it yes yeah we are
you know and like we're so thrilled to
be on the cover of the not i'm talking
about it here on on your show drew our
show because it's important to us to
share our love with the world and and we
made a conscious decision to do that
because why well because you know
growing up an immigrant from dominican
republic and him being a little farm boy
from mount vernon you know we never saw
that and it's important to actually have
that representation out there and you
know just value that any anyone can
actually have that as well so yeah
we didn't growing up think about that we
didn't even know
we didn't even dream about getting
married one day because it wasn't even
an option for us you know and so we
think by sharing our love story and and
showing it to everyone maybe there's a
little kid out there who who can look at
us and go oh my god i deserve that i
deserve love
and the
energy
that you put into it
is just a such a loving energy but also
having fun yes and every time i see you
guys doing your thing it reminds me to
enjoy life more yeah it really does it's
so inspiring that's the nicest thing oh
[Applause]
you know that is the biggest compliment
you can give it's true that's what i get
from you guys just as an innocent
bystander and right in the middle of it
it's both yeah we're just so so grateful
you know especially
where we come from you know growing up
as little gay kids is not the easiest
thing in the world and the world in
itself has been sort of a dark place
lately and so
to have this sort of joy um
we're filled with gratitude and we just
want to share it with everybody welly
can i ask you a question because i
i i get to
be with my lucky co-pilot all the time
who is your co-pilot in in life
um what is it that you really admire in
rossi tell me one thing you admire about
him and then i have a follow-up question
just one
oh good answer that's good
that's good
no his heart drew you know his heart is
just so
loving and just he gives it to everyone
and honestly he's just the sweetest
person that i've ever met and his humor
that's what i have to say more than one
and you you and him have this you know
chemistry that just like
i i want you to know how much you mean
to us honestly and we love you so much
and because of you it's why we are in
the same state right now oh i'm so
relieved because i am totally third
wheeling it with you guys and also it's
like which i like i don't know i like
being a third one yeah we're like a
wheel but come on yeah
is stronger
we are the hottest threat on daytime
television and you know the struggles
are trending
now everybody look for this beautiful
issue on newsstands it'll be everywhere
april 26th well guess what the people
from the knot are here right here
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you guys thank you thank you for
making this happen i just want to say
too as a lover of magazines i just think
this cover is so beautiful the inside
and i am such a big fan of the knot
[Music]
you